good morning Hank it's Monday I woke up
on Friday around 8 a.m. in Los Angeles
the city of palm trees pleasant weather
news helicopters prestigious zip codes
terrible traffic and astonishingly
sparse mobile internet as I drove over
to my friend ransoms house I heard on
the radio there had been an earthquake
and a tsunami in Japan and I was so
wrapped up in the news that I got lost
and since my phone didn't work as a
mobile atlas anymore I had to call
ransom for directions I mean I see a
sign that says motion I see a sign that
says San Vicente and the signs seemed to
imply that there's a perpendicular
rather than parallel relationship
between those two places but what you're
seeing on the map disagrees with that
finally made it to his house we went
inside and read about the earthquake and
then somehow got to talking about his
photographs ransom collects photographs
taken of and by people he doesn't know
he has thousands of them in these
plastic slip cases and he's obsessed
with the stories that these photographs
contain particularly when you flip them
over this one for instance rock wall
near Rose Bowl Pasadena California where
Dorothy found a baby girl On January
24th 1961 Hank ransom used photographs
like this one to make one of the
greatest YouTube videos of all time link
in the doobly-doo we drove down to the
beach then where this newscaster was
like this very ocean just devastated
Japan and then I ran into the water like
a boss forgetting that I had shoes on
then Randy took me over to the Venice
canals a few blocks of La that looked
like Southern California and Amsterdam
had a baby and we walked around talking
about how weird it was to stroll these
sun-drenched canals on such a tragic day
but then really all human life has lived
in close proximity to tragedy
we saw bird flowers and a park for ducks
and these Turtles too quiet for the
camera to hear ransom said wouldn't it
be sad if a child's pool were enough to
imprison you then I had to leave for a
wedding so I participated in an activity
that people in Los Angeles called
hopping on the freeway which does not in
any way resemble hopping as I idled back
toward our hotel the news on the radio
got worse and worse and then I put on a
suit and went to the wedding the
reception was at a beautiful home in
Beverly Hills and as I drank free
champagne and looked out over the pool I
thought about how even though we were
kind of in a desert the water had been
everywhere that day from the pool to my
champagne glass from the turtle pond to
the canals to the ocean I found myself
wishing there were some way for those of
us on one side of an ocean to tell
people on the other side that we were
thinking
of them a way that I could say that not
only to the people of Japan but also to
Dorothy who'd found that baby girl in
1961 but images can travel in a way that
our thoughts cannot and that night I
felt sad and frustrated that technology
can never quite bridge the oceans
between us Hank you'll find a link to
the Red Cross Disaster Relief Fund in
the doobly-doo welcome back from Haiti
I'll see you on Wednesday